Jay, I'm Jad Abumrad. This is more perfect,
a mini series about the supreme court to begin. By the way,
I'll will explain the top title of this podcast. At the end.
We live in a democracy with three branches in it,
you've got the executive branch, the legislative branch,
and the judicial branch.
Now that third branch did judicial the courts consists of about a hundred ish
federal courts and on top of those courts is Ville court. This, this,
this temple of nine now eight unelected lifetime appointees who seem to have
this tremendous power, almost tyrannical power.
They are wickedly important and we're reminded of this.
Scalia's death throws a huge unknown factor into this campaign.
Every time we turn on the TV,
we are one justice away from losing our fundamental rights in this country
because here we are in an election and the phrase that you hear a lot,
one of the most important things in that election,
I think this might be the most important thing to those of you who are young
outside of today is that one of the most important things.
The next president's going to do this next president may very well a point
between one and three, four supreme court justices. No, nevermind that.
Most Americans have no idea who the justices are.
Two thirds can't even name a single justice.
I can't even name the one that just died.
I honestly couldn't tell you any of their names. Okay.
I am either the name of a judge. I know judge Judy, doesn't matter.
We all know that whoever they are, they're incredibly powerful people.
Did they can boom instantly strike down a law that took years to pass.
Supreme Court reversed a century of law that I believe will open the flood
gates. They can undo executive orders.
They can even change like these long held definitions like what makes a person,
what makes a marriage? They can even decide an election justice Scalia,
my usual response is get over it.
Get over the possible corrupting of the American President
[inaudible].
Now with all the background chatter in the election,
it's sorta interesting to think about the fact that when it comes to the court
in their power, it didn't have to be this way.
It didn't have to be this way and it wasn't for a long time and it wasn't for a
long time. Yeah. Reporter Kelsey paget, we'll take it from here.
I mean if you go back in time,
say like early 18 hundreds the court had so little power.
In fact, they were meeting in the basement of Congress.
That's a Linda monk constitutional scholar.
One newspaper refers to it later as a dark,
Dank potato potato. Like it was damn for something.
I mean, DC at this time was like a swamp.
So I imagine they were spiders in there and they said there weren't very many
windows. Well, maybe it wasn't that bad,
but still we think of three separate branches.
It's kind of hard to think of yourself as a separate branch when you're meeting
in the basement of Congress. Not only that,
when Congress actually sets up the first Supreme Court,
they created originally a supreme court of the six justices.
That's your law professor. Akil Reed. Omar, an even number.
How odd. They were freaked out. Oh, the court could be divided for four.
What's going to happen? Oh my God, that'd be a four four split.
You could [inaudible] supreme court is not designed to function with an even
number of justice. You know, we're,
we're in a crisis or cable news be creating their constitutional crisis
graphics. Originally, the first congress,
they created six members because they're not imagining the court as deciding
everything. In other words, like if the court split,
who cares? Because at the time they weren't deciding big cases.
They weren't deciding like affirmative action, Roe v Wade, nothing like that.
They were nailing like these little tiny rinky-dink cases and most of their time
was spent literally riding and carriages from town to town trying cases around
the country and that's a big hassle.
They don't even get to sleep in their own bed. Wait, why are they riding around?
Well,
so they actually each had a separate geographical zone that they're in charge
of. That's actually still true today, but unlike today, wouldn't w where people,
you know, come to the Supreme Court back then, people weren't coming to them.
Why would I do that? That's Ellie, Ellie, Mr. Hall, our legal editor.
Why would I go seek out these guys someplace else to hear my local issue in
South Carolina? If they have something to say about it,
they can come to South Carolina and sit on my farm and talk to me.
We've got to think about the,
about the country in 1800 and 1804 this is a states rights states centric
country, all of which is to say that being a supreme court justice at the time,
it's not a great gig. It's, it's rough.
Consequently that people who chose to do this well
I got investments. Ah Yeah,
totally Ma and who are like really smart but like a motley crew that isn't
organized. That's all right. Savitsky he's a lawyer.
Constitutional history enthusiast.
He says at the time on the court you had this one guy nicknamed old bacon face
who has is like a maniac.
He's like the kind of like Charlie Sheen wild thing and major league type
character. Very hot tempered, had a foul mouth.
There's another one who um,
you know is like four foot five and like really silent.
The supreme court was like a pretty ragtag bunch.
All of this happens and I think it's important for,
for people to understand all of this happens in part because the constitution is
embarrassingly silent on what the Supreme Court is,
what it should do, how it should be constituted. Article Three says,
article three of our United States constitution says there shall be a supreme
court. Thanks guys.
It's true. I mean it's kind of weird like if you read the comments
institution,
we had spends a lot of time talking about the House of Representatives.
How are you going to count slaves and it's going to be by population.
There has to be a census every 10 years because the house is important. But
when it comes to the Supreme Court, all you get is like a couple of sentences,
almost nothing at all. You know, and that's, that's of the puzzle of this.
Like how did they get so powerful? I mean,
they started out as, it's like
nobody's in a basement and now they're these all powerful,
you know, priests of the Constitution,
the Supreme Court of the United States, nine men and women,
high end government who sit in judgment on many of the great questions before
our nation. So how did that happen?
[inaudible]
especially when there's like arguably nothing in the constitution that said that
that should happen. All right, so how did it happen? Well,
you can trace so much of this back to one move by one man,
John Marshall, John Marshall, John Marshall, the new chief justice,
he writes to the court in 1801 Marshall calls his first meeting of the court
and one person shows up. What do you mean the other terror?
They've got something better to do. Like they just don't show up.
Actually it was three, but still, maybe before we go too deep.
Can you just like, what did he look like? Oh, they all looked the same to me.
He didn't mean that he was tall.
He was gone hit a square jaw for jowly piercing eyes.
Marshall was, this was a smart cookie.
And he would need to be because he ends up getting in this very famous fight
with his very famous second cousin that would change the course of the American
history like forever. Who's is a very famous second cousin?
Well it just a little man named Thomas Jefferson.
Oh t J now. John Marshall and Thomas Jefferson. We're here. We really,
really don't like each other.
I mean on a personal level you think Hamilton and Jefferson is something on
Broadway?
Actually it was Marshall and Jefferson who really despised each other and yet
they both come from Virginia.
They both come from the back country while the hate,
well I mean part of it was this like family beef at one point.
John Marshall's wife's mother rejected Thomas Jefferson romantically.
Yeah, his wife's mother. Yeah. So he's his mother-in-law. Yeah.
No two the Great Thomas Jefferson. No,
but that doesn't seem like enough of a reason. Well I mean, okay,
so the main reason,
the non gossipy reason,
the non fun reason just because they were an opposite political parties.
I think an important thing to understand about Marshall is that he's a party
man. Okay. Party man. He's a party man. Like he likes to party. Uh,
he, he, he's committed to his team and his team is, um, our, the federalists,
the federalists. They love big government. Let's have a national bank.
It's rev up national power. The Republicans, Thomas Jefferson's people,
they like small, tiny government. Let the states have the power that, you know,
we're maybe even in favor of the view that states can veto federal law if they
don't like it. So these two guys, these two cousins,
both national figures, totally different philosophies.
And even before Marshall Hits the court,
they're going at it, they beef and they beef and they'd be actually a slug fest.
To Paraphrase Marshall, you're dishonest Jefferson. You're a hack Marshall.
You and your friends are poisoning America. Dislike that it's a food fight.
It's very difficult to stop the tendency to view the people that you disagree
with as, um, as evil.
Somebody that can take our jobs back, right? Because we're going to hell.
It's just really hard. We do that today all the time. Right? They even as much,
if not more than today.
They thought that the other side was trying to destroy the America that they had
just created
anyway. Drought, the 1790s the federalists are in power.
The federalist hold all the, you know, branches of government.
John Adams is the president, mostly loved by his own party.
Hated by Thomas Jefferson's party.
They literally call him like his Roatan diddy. Very offensive.
So Adams is a power and ultimately our guy, John Marshall,
Marshall is secretary of state,
one of the highest officials in the Adams administration, you know, party man.
And for a while things are going well for his party. But then
[inaudible]
Thomas Jefferson and the Republicans sweep in and crush,
absolutely crushed the federalists. Like landslide crush. Yeah,
Fleetwood Mac style.
They're republicans ran the table in 1800 they're going to take over the house.
They're going to take over the presidency. So John Adams is like, crap,
what do I do? We need to save the republic.
Ah, the federalists have basically been swept out, but in his dire moment,
he has this idea. He's thinking like, Oh, I've lost the house.
I've lost the White House. Oh, this supreme court, the Supreme Court.
And normally nobody cares about the supreme court,
but like in this moment he's thinking, oh my gosh, this is my last hope.
And in fact, as luck would have it,
a vacancy pops up a vacant chief justice position. Um,
so just as justice Scalia's recently died and there's a vacancy, well the,
the sitting chief justice Oliver Ellsworth steps down and Adams picks his
secretary of State John Marshall to be the new chief justice.
That's how we got John Marshall. And John Adams says one other thing
in the waning seconds of his presidency,
Adams and these reputed federalists jam through a whole bunch of federal
judgeships.
They create scores of new judges and they throw federalists into almost all of
those positions. Like 40 appointments.
He just throws in 40 judges right at the last minute.
Hollars creates 40 judges at the last minute and then he appoints 40 chairs.
Wow. I fired Jefferson. I would be pissed. Jefferson is pest,
which we'll get to in a second. But the meantime,
Adam says just a few days left in his presidency.
So he's like frantically trying to get all these judges in,
nominate these people, confirm that once you confirm someone,
you have to like give them their commission.
You can't just go around claiming you're a judge or claiming or whatever.
You have to have a commission,
like a piece of paper with the formal seal and the signature of the president.
And as the story goes, as the clock is striking,
midnight on John Adams's last day,
Adams and his team there in his office and they're trying to get these papers
out the door. They're frantically signing them, stamping them.
I just imagine like young boys sprinting through the dead of night,
he's waving these papers over their head, no commission. The fact that the like,
I think totally Apocryphal story is that Jefferson's attorney general like lots
in the door at midnight and he's like, yeah, put down your pen. You know,
don't do it. So, but apparently some of the commissions don't get delivered.
[inaudible]
they just are left sitting on the desk because,
is it like an oversight or something or clerical error?
It's not even like a click. They just ran out of time. Oh.
But they thought like if a couple are left on the desk, it's no big deal.
If it is like it's a signed commission from the president and it's like still a
binding docket. The fact that it wasn't formally delivered, you know,
you still get your appointments.
So this sets up this like kinda terrible situation for Jefferson.
He shows up the next day to take power and the judiciary
[inaudible] is filled with ghosts of presidential appointees past just
[inaudible]
bastion of partisan judges.
so as you can imagine, Jefferson and his friends think that this,
this is not fair.
Jefferson sees Marshall and all of the other judges that Adam's appointed as
Adams, his spies on his administration. So Jefferson,
he decides to immediately retaliate because you know, he won the presidency,
he won by a lot
and he's like, you're shoving all these judges down my throat.
And on top of that, the guy you've named to be the head of the judges,
the head of the Supreme Court is my evil second cousin. Whoa. What is this?
So Jefferson is running the country
[inaudible]
and working with the Republican Congress too.
Yeah.
Among other things had sold the supreme court term for 1802
they just canceled the whole term. They just canceled it.
They were like say like go home. Yeah. They were like,
there's no more supreme court. Sorry.
Imagine if that happened today when Obama's plan for immigration gets mapped
out,
imagine to him like instead of having like that peaceful press conference where
he like shows us disappointment.
Imagine instead he was like Supreme Court though your room. No good pumps.
That's right. Anyhow, Marshall send away for over a year.
There's no full supreme court meetings and when he comes back,
it's pretty clear to him that the supreme court, it's on life support
that the Republicans could pull the plug in any minute.
Marshall knows already that there are there rumblings that one of his
colleagues, Amanda man named Chase Old Bacon face,
you know Becca should be impeached.
So when he sees this motley crew and a dark dank potato hall,
he's like, I gotta do something. We're fighting for our life here.
I was thinking about this on the way over and it kind of reminds me of,
you know those like summer camp movies where there's like a baseball team and
they're like super ragtag and like can't get it together.
And then like at the end they have to, I play the really good team with the,
like the nice professional uniforms that's kind of like the judges on the
Supreme Court and Marshall is kind of like the counselor or the camper,
you know, with the new kid on the [inaudible]
black hoop who comes to the team and is like, we can do this guys. We can do it.
Cue Eighties Movie Training Model
[inaudible]
he knows that if the u s is even going to have a court system of the supreme
court, he's got a beef this team up.
One of the first things that Marshall does is just professionalize the
judiciary. Like so for example, he starts this tradition of wearing black robes.
Does that make them look, the part that is appeared in their robes of justice?
He figured that the black robes would make them look less like partisan hacks
and more like
[inaudible].
They're floating above the fray
beyond politics.
Next, he moved all the justices into this one door,
the same rooming house. No wives, no family, all business.
He's trying to create that more perfect union in the judiciary.
And just to grease the wheels a little bit, how does somebody wrote my dear?
Is that some wine? Yes. Pod. It's a fortified wine.
Goldman Justice Marshall will order it in great quantities that many scholars
think was part of John Marshall Secret.
Okay, so he's professionalizing the team, he's getting them together,
and then they get put to the test in 1803 it's a cousin on cousins smackdown
that's coming up and we continue.
This is more perfect.
[inaudible]
he's from Washington, from snap, snap duckling live lots.
Nashville Wyman theater fighting March 16th and I'm bringing the best
[inaudible] in the world. Friday laughs.
Amazing night out and yes, she's coming. The funniest woman in the world.
Jen Kober. I'm do my hung in the lady forest.
Gen POBA rock's a brand new story. Get tickets.
It's snap judgment.org I've never gotten applause for it before.
If you guys could call my mom, that'd be awesome. She's still pissed.
Yay. I'm Jad Abumrad this is more perfect.
Back to our story from Kelsey paget and we arrive at the pivotal moment that
cousin on cousin's smackdown that would change America. Okay,
so remember how Ra told us that some of those commissions didn't get delivered?
Yeah,
think five and that they were just like sitting on a desk somewhere and how they
thought it wasn't a big deal because it's still a binding document. Well,
when Jefferson comes to power, apparently he finds those papers and it's like,
oh look at this. You didn't deliver these commissions.
Guess you can't get those positions. Sorry.
And one of the people that I'm lost out because they're commission did not get
delivered was one Mr. William Marbury, whose businessman,
39 years of age, he got appointed to be justice of the peace.
It's a pretty low ranking position.
So he's sitting there and he's waiting for his commission to show up and like,
of course it never does. And it finally dawns on him like, Oh,
the Jefferson administration has it. Aye, I'm going to go get it.
He files a lawsuit. So,
and what he does is he actually ends up being really important,
but he files a lawsuit directly in the Supreme Court. Hey, you can do that.
You can just go right to the supreme court like first. Well,
at this time Congress had just passed a law that said like in certain very
strange circumstances, you can just go directly to the Supreme Court.
He goes directly to the Supreme Court and he says, I have a right.
I have a legal right.
I want you the Supreme Court to order Thomas Jefferson.
Give me that darn piece of paper that says I'm really a judge.
The case gets named Marbury v Madison because James Madison is Jefferson
Secretary of state who is actually suing,
but he's essentially suing the president,
forcing Marshall in the court to have this confrontation with Jefferson.
So now it's the showdown. It's between Marshall's Ragtag team and Jefferson
[inaudible].
So basically what happens is the court has a trial
Marbury and his lawyers, they get up there and they're like,
what happened to the papers? Where is the commission? Did you have them?
What'd you do with them? Jefferson? The people get up there and say, Bob,
I don't know what you're talking about.
I won't answer the question of what happened to them.
They stonewall to which Marbury's lawyers are like, seriously,
these are all look important. Official documents signed by the president.
Like no one knows what happened in them. They go back and forth, back and forth.
Things get very tense and you know, I mean to their credit, like no one,
like punched out.
Eventually they stop arguing about whether or not the papers exist and they're
like, this is the more important question.
Does the Jefferson administration have to honor those papers?
Do they have to give the commission to Marbury? Are they required?
Is there a legal requirement that they give it to them?
And in Marshall's head it's a resounding hell yeah,
he should've gotten that commission because the law is the,
and if you decide you're not going to follow the law just because you don't like
the guy who made the law or you don't think it's fair,
that's anarchy. I mean that's, we, we talk a lot in this country.
We pat ourselves on the back in this country about our peaceful transfer of
power.
Ellie ms doll again about how we seamlessly can go from one party to another
party without bloodshed in the streets in whatever. Good for us.
But what, how do we actually get to that point?
And this is a key reason why we've gotten to that point because the decisions of
the past administration still hold value.
Even when that administration is kicked out of office,
kind of overthrown by popular vote.
Their decisions still have still have sway, still have a legal force.
Jefferson was quite obviously negating that.
So Marshall wants to say to Jefferson, you know, suck it up cousin.
You have this guy whose papers, you're an official do your job,
but he thinks twice.
He understands how weak his court is according to to kill a Mar.
Marshall's afraid that if he orders Jefferson to give over those papers,
Jefferson is going to straight up laugh in his face and say you and what army,
I'm not going to do it.
Literally they just got back from a congressionally mandated.
You can't come to work time.
Jefferson knows full well that he has no intention of granting that commission.
He will never give that commission. Jefferson knows this, Marshall knows this.
Marshall knows that if he tells Jefferson to give him the commission,
Jefferson is going to ignore him and then the power of the supreme court
basically evaporates because Ellie says like if you think about it,
if the executive branch is going to say kind of right at the jump that if you
make a decision they don't like, I'm just going to ignore that.
Then every executive branch going on from Jefferson throughout the rest of our
history is going to just ignore the supreme court when the Supreme Court does
something that the executive doesn't like.
So basically Marshall's kind of stuck
[inaudible]
if he rules for Jefferson,
he's selling out the law and he's going to make the court look weak.
If he rules against
Jefferson Jefferson's gonna ignore the court and they're going to look weak.
Either way, Jefferson wins and either way,
supreme court maybe disappears forever.
Marshall needed to find a way to get through this.
He needed to find some way to kick this case. To be clear,
John Marshall is running away from a fight with Thomas Jefferson.
He says all sorts of things, but he knows the Thomas Jefferson,
you know, straight up has more power and so he's retreating. Wow.
It's like suddenly feels like an apocalyptical moment. Yeah. What does he do?
Well, so the thing that he does,
it's like the most Jedi mastering thing ever.
He writes this hundred something page decision and in the beginning if you
actually read the decision, it's a lot of pages of telling Jefferson
how he's
wrong, how he can't do what he did,
how he is, you know, ruining America. Right.
There's a lot of that and the Marshall decision,
but then when he gets to the matter at hand, he does this little
shift. So he says, okay, hold up.
Yes Marbury is right. He should've gotten that commission.
And yes, Mr. Jefferson should not be doing this,
but we the supreme court, we don't have jurisdiction to hear this case.
Yeah.
Courtney is to have the power to hear a case and if a court doesn't have the
power to hear a case, even if you're completely right,
even if your position is right, you can't get relief. Wait,
why would he say that they don't have jurisdiction with this is like where he
uses the force. You know,
earlier I had mentioned that Marbury brought this case under a law congress had
passed that said Marbury could come straight to the supreme court,
like for this kind of situation. Well, John Marshall,
he goes back to his constitution. He's reading around, he's like, guys,
I'm trying to figure out like what he can do here.
And he finds his little sentence. Yeah. So it's article three,
section two in the constitution that says like,
basically you're not supposed to go to the supreme court first.
You're supposed to go to a different court and then the supreme court,
it's an appeals court. Wonky. Exactly. But,
but he basically tells Marbury the plaintiff,
you came in and you came to the Supreme Court first and you did that because
Congress passed a law that said that you could come to the supreme court first,
but the constitution says that you can't come to the supreme court first.
So I can't help you. Nope. It's not your fault, Mr Marbury.
But that law was unconstitutional and we're not going to follow that
unconstitutional directive. So you see what he did there?
Aye,
maybe. I see. I don't know if I see, you know,
that part in star wars was a week.
The first one where Obi wan Kenobi is fighting with Darth Vader. And he says,
strike me, Don. All powerful. Anyone possibly imagined
this is like that,
but real Marshall is agreeing to lose.
He's like found this way to lose to like let Darth Vader strike him down and
that's actually gonna make it more powerful.
He's basically saying to his cousin, Oh, okay,
you don't have to give my braise commission.
And the reason you don't have to give my RIAs commission is a cause that law
doesn't work because we, the court,
we get to decide when something agrees with or doesn't agree with constitution.
So like Kratz UN cousin, Oh and by the way,
we, the court have the power to declare things unconstitutional.
That was the sort of Jedi master move. That's the move.
Instead of jumping off the cliff for laying down,
he jukes to the right and he establishes a new rule of the game unconstitutional
inside this one highly technical,
highly political drama between these two cousins.
John Marshall sneaks in an atomic bomb.
This incredible power
[inaudible]
and in Marshall's decision you wrote is some Fadli the duty and provenance of
the judicial department to say what the law is.
Say what the law is to say what the law is, and with those words,
he made the court what it is today.
The U S Supreme Court ruled Monday a law allowing Americans born in Jerusalem to
list Israel as their place of birth is unconstitutional, is unconstitutional.
Now Doma is ruled unconstitutional, unconstitutional, unconstitutional,
unconstitutional, and no one had ever done that before. Well,
I mean like people talked about it,
lots of theories about it in some smaller courts, smaller decisions,
but this is the first time that the supreme court does it and he does it in the
face of the president.
Just wait,
Ernesto,
a Miranda petitioner versus Arizona connection against the United States
that set us on this path.
New York Times company, petitioner versus lb
day. The court is so much more powerful.
It's grown into the 800 pound gorilla. When it slam says jump.
Other branches tend to say how high we'll hear argument now a number,
oh nine 49 George W.
Bush and Richard [inaudible] were just taking for granted three words.
Bush v Gore. They decided to presidential election and and no one blinked.
Let me just jump in for one second. Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, you could be,
if we have to say this before we close,
you could reasonably argue that Marbury versus Madison was not the big moment
when the court got its power because it really depends on what you mean when you
say power.
Like I guess we were talking with our legal editor, Ellie, Ms [inaudible],
constitutional scholar, Linda monk. They both said like,
look at what happens after this case. Just 30 years down the road, ish.
John Marshall's still the chief justice.
He gets into a dustup with Andrew Jackson and this is Jackson we're talking
about. So generally it was,
I would like to do horrible things to native Americans, and the court was like,
you probably shouldn't do horrible things than native Americans.
And Jackson was like, shut up.
I don't remember asking you a God damn thing to essentially you had a situation
where Marshall makes a ruling saying we have to respect native American
sovereignty. And Andrew Jackson famously said, oh, supposedly said,
we don't know if that's true. Oh look,
I think it's more fun to believe that Jackson did say that it works better than
the musical. Okay. The court has made its ruling. Now let them enforce it.
John Marshall has made his decision now let him enforce it and obviously he
couldn't. So to make a long set story short, you get the trail of tears.
Thousands of native Americans were marched off their lands.
There's evidence that
they were purposefully moved during the winter so that more people would die
along the way. So while the court maybe had constitutional authority,
it didn't have actual power
until we just got here on this end that the students are fast forward to the
1950s court order schools to desegregate, they don't.
And the president sends him the troops,
takes Eisenhower directing the youtube groups on the putting boots on the
ground, picks Kennedy
of Alabama National God-man,
putting boots on the ground takes force.
It's still so often comes down to an executive willing to put boots on the
ground in order to enforce their laws.
That's when the power becomes real.
Although maybe not
la, I don't know.
A time before I went to college and even shortly after I was in college where
things were not separate.
At one point as we were working on the story,
Ellie talked to his mom and she told him that when she was growing up in the mid
sixties, and this is years after desegregation,
more than a decade past Brown v Board, you would still never know what happened.
No one would know it. And Clarksdale,
Mississippi at that time there was a public library,
but I was not allowed to go to that library. My father,
who was Chinese, could go into the library.
So many times I sit in the car while that went into a library to get a book that
I wanted.
And this is, this is after the passage of the Civil Rights Act even. Yes.
I'm saying high school. I graduated in 67
67. Wow. Just yesterday as we're recording this, um, uh,
court had to issue a current court had to issue a nother ruling ordering a town
in Mississippi to desegregate its schools. Yeah. That,
that didn't happen five years ago. Then how that happened yesterday, man,
yesterday, the courts can make these laws,
but if the people aren't willing to go along with it,
then what do these laws mean?
I think ultimately I agree with learning hand.
He was a judge in New York in the early 19 hundreds that we place our hopes too
much upon laws and courts and constitutions,
that these are false hopes. Liberty lies in the hearts of men and women,
and when it dies, there no law, no court, no constitution can save it.
[inaudible]
in the end, for better or worse, we,
the people still have the power.
[inaudible]
okay,
so why do we call this podcast the strange thing we called it as it turns out,
well, I guess we mentioned this at the top. Vast majority of Americans,
like 66% cannot name a single supreme court justice.
We also found that when we went out,
a lot of people had no idea how many justices.
I do not know how many Supreme Court justices that, I'm not sure.
12 or a couple of hundred. One Sarah, seven Supreme Court judges,
maybe 12, nine, nine. Yes. We'll know eight.
Uh, we think we should know about these people.
We should at least know their names.
So the title of this podcast is a pneumonic device to help you remember the
names of the justices. So their last names are Kagan,
Kennedy, Thomas Ginsburg, briars. Sorry, Briar,
no s there, Roberts, Alito and Sotomayor. And if Merrick garland gets on,
then you've also got garland, Kagan, Kennedy, Thomas Ginsburg, Briar Roberts,
Alito, Stoudamire, maybe garland. So first letter, last name, k, k,
t. G. B. R. A. S, maybe g.
What if we turn that into a song to help you remember
kittens, tick Kigali, blue robot all cellar.
Maybe. God Damn.
Can you kittens? Giggly boo robot all sober.
Maybe got kittens. [inaudible]
maybe Goddamn
[inaudible]. [inaudible] maybe Goddamn kittens.
Oh, sorry. Baby
kittens. [inaudible] robot
[inaudible] maybe
[inaudible]
skinny, thin giggling. Oh Man. Oh. So
maybe Goddamn you can find that song, uh,
on our website. Radio lab.org/more. Perfect.
And now you make one send it to us.
Oh, seriously?
More perfect. Is produced by me, Jenn Evan, Rod, Susie,
left and Berg and Lo Kelsey Padgett and Sean Ramez from with Soren Wheeler,
Ellie Ms Style, David Herman, Alex Overington, Karen Duffin, Catherine Wells,
Barry Finkle, Andy Mills, Dylan, Keith, and Eva Dasher.
Special thanks to Judith Resnick, Paul Boger. Liam told Jessica Miller,
Annie Mcewen, Matthew, Matt Kielty, Aletha, John Mead, Bernard,
Nadia Sirota and John Hanrahan Supreme Court. Audio is from OEA,
a free law project and collaboration with the legal information institute at
Cornell.
More perfect is funded in part by the William and Flora Hewlett Foundation,
the Charles Evans Hughes Memorial Foundation and the Joyce Foundation.
Yeah, I'm Jad Abumrad. This is more perfect.
Back to our story from Kelsey Padgett and we arrive at the pivotal moment that
cousin on cousin's smackdown that would change America. Okay,
so remember how Ra told us that some of those commissions didn't get delivered,
think five and that they were just like sitting on a desk somewhere and how they
thought it wasn't a big deal because it's still a binding document. Well,
when Jefferson comes to power, apparently he finds those papers and it's like,
oh look at this, you didn't deliver these commissions,
guess you can't get those positions. Sorry.
And one of the people that um,
lost out because they're commissioned and not get delivered was one Mr. William
Marbury, he is a businessman, 39 years of age,
he got appointed to be justice of the peace. It's a pretty low ranking position.
So he's sitting there and he's waiting for his commission to show up and like,
of course it never does. And it finally dawns on him like, Oh,
the Jefferson administration has it. Aye, I'm going to go get it.
He files a lawsuit. So,
and what he does is he actually ends up being really important,
but he follows the lawsuit directly in the Supreme Court. You can do that.
You can just go right to the supreme court. Like first at this time,
Congress had just passed a law that said like in certain very strange
circumstances, you can just go directly to the Supreme Court.
He goes directly to the Supreme Court and he says, I have a right.
I have a legal right.
I want you the Supreme Court to order Thomas Jefferson.
Give me that darn piece of paper that says I'm really a judge.
The case gets named Marbury v Madison because James Madison is Jefferson
Secretary of state who is actually suing,
but he's essentially suing the president,
forcing Marshall in the court to have this confrontation with Jefferson.
So now it's the showdown. It's between Marshall's rag tag team and Jefferson
[inaudible].
So basically what happens is the court has a trial
Marbury and his lawyers, they get up there and they're like,
what happened to the papers? Where is the commission? Did you have them?
What'd you do with them? Jefferson people get up there and say, man,
I don't know what you're talking about. I won't answer the question.
What happened them? They stonewall to which Marbury's lawyers are like,
seriously,
these are all like important official documents signed by the president.
Like no one knows what happened in them. Like it's like they go back and forth,
back and forth. Things get very tense and you know, I mean to their credit,
like no one like punched out.
Eventually they stop arguing about whether or not the papers exist and they're
like, this is the more important question.
Does the Jefferson administration have to honor those papers?
Do they have to give the commission to Marbury? Are they required?
Is there a legal requirement that they give it to them?
And in Marshall's head it's a resounding hell yeah,
he should've gotten that commission because the law is the law.
And if you decide you're not going to follow the law just because you don't like
the guy who made the law or you don't think it's fair,
that's anarchy. I mean that's, we, we talk a lot in this country.
We pat ourselves on the back in this country about our peaceful transfer of
power,
Ellie ms doll again about how we seamlessly can go from one party to the other
party without bloodshed in the streets and whatever, Eh, good for us.
But what, how do we actually get to that point?
And this is a key reason why we've gotten to that point because the decisions of
the past administration still hold the value.
Even when that administration is kicked out of office,
kind of overthrown by popular vote,
their decisions still have still have sway, still have a legal force.
Jefferson was quite obviously uh,
negating that.
So Marshall wants to say to Jefferson, you know, suck it up, cousin,
give this guy his papers. You're an official, do your job. But he thinks twice.
He understands how weak his court is. According to Kiel.
Amar Marshall is afraid that if he orders Jefferson to give over those papers,
Jefferson is going to straight up laugh in his face and see you and what army,
I'm not going to do it.
Literally they just got back from a congressionally mandated.
You can't come to work time.
Jefferson knows full well that he has no intention of granting that commission.
He will never give that commission. Jefferson knows this, Marshall knows this.
Marshall knows that if he tells Jefferson to give him the commission,
Jefferson is going to ignore him and then the power of the supreme court
basically evaporates because Ellie says like if you think about it,
if the executive branch is going to say kind of right at the jump that if you
make a decision they don't like, I'm just going to ignore that.
Then every executive branch going on from Jefferson throughout the rest of our
history is going to just ignore this important court when the supreme court does
something that the executive doesn't like.
So basically Marshall's kind of stuck
[inaudible]
if he rules for Jefferson,
he's selling out the law and he's going to make the court look weak.
If you rules against
Jefferson Jefferson's gonna ignore the court and they're going to look weak.
Either way, Jefferson wins and either way,
supreme court maybe disappears forever.
Marshall needed to find a way to get through this.
He needed to find some way to kick this case. To be clear,
John Marshall is running away from a fight with Thomas Jefferson.
He says all sorts of things that he knows the Thomas Jefferson, you know,
straight up has more power and so he's retreating. Wow.
It's like suddenly feels like an apocalyptical moment. Yeah.
What does he do well, so the thing that he does,
it's like the most Jedi masters thing ever.
He writes this hundred something page decision and in the beginning if you
actually read the decision, it's a lot of pages of telling Jefferson
how he's wrong, how he can't do what he did,
how he is, you know, ruining America. Right.
There's a lot of that in the Marshall decision,
but then when it gets to the matter at hand, he does this little
shift. So he says, okay, hold up.
Yes Marbury is right. He should have gotten that commission. And yes,
Mr. Jefferson should not be doing this, but we the supreme court,
we don't have jurisdiction to hear this case.
Court needs to have the power to hear a case and have a court doesn't have the
power to hear a case. Even if you're completely right,
and even if your position is right, you can't get relief. Wait.
Why would he say that they don't have jurisdiction with [inaudible]?
This is like where he uses the force. You know,
earlier I had mentioned that Marbury brought this case under a law congress had
passed that said Marbury could come straight to the supreme court,
like for this kind of situation. Well, John Marshall,
he goes back to his constitution, he's reading around,
he's like guys trying to figure out like what he can do here and he finds this
little sentence. So it's article three,
section two in the constitution that says like basically you're not supposed to
go to the supreme court first.
You're supposed to go to a different court and then the supreme court,
it's an appeals court. [inaudible] exactly. But,
but he basically tells Marbury the plaintiff,
you came in and you came to the Supreme Court first and you did that because
Congress passed a law that said that you could come to the supreme court first.
But the constitution says that you can't come to the supreme court first.
So I can't help you. Nope, it's not your fault, Mr Marbury.
But that law was unconstitutional and we're not going to follow that
unconstitutional directive. So you see what he did there?
I maybe I see it. I don't know if I see, okay,
so with you that you know that part in star wars,
it was a week old man.
The first one where Obi wan Kenobi is fighting with Darth Vader. And he says,
strike me. [inaudible] powerful. Possibly. Imagine
this is like that.
But Real Marshall is agreeing to lose. He's like,
found this way to lose to like let Darth Vader strike him down.
That's actually gonna make it more powerful.
He's basically saying to his cousin,
Oh, okay, you don't have to give Marbury's commission.
And the reason you don't have to give Barbara his commission is a cause that law
doesn't work because we, the court,
we get to decide when something agrees with or doesn't agree with constitution.
So like, congrats, you win cousin. Oh, and by the way,
we, the court have the power to declare things unconstitutional.
That was the sort of Jedi master move. That's the move.
Instead of jumping off the cliff or laying down you jukes to the right and he
establishes a new rule of the game. Are you constitutional?
[inaudible]
inside this one, highly technical,
highly political drama between these
two cousins. John Marshall sneaks in an atomic bomb.
This incredible power
in Marshall's decision he wrote is some Fadli the duty and province of the
judicial department to say what the law is. Say what the law is,
say what the law is,
and with those words he made the court what it is today.
The US Supreme Court ruled Monday a law allowing Americans born in Jerusalem to
list Israel as their place of birth is unconstitutional, is unconstitutional.
Now Doma is ruled unconstitutional, unconstitutional, unconstitutional,
unconstitutional, and no one had ever done that before. Well,
I mean like people talked about it,
lots of theories about it and some smaller courts, smaller decisions.
But this is the first time that the supreme court does it and he does it in the
face of the president against wait,
Ernesto,
a Miranda petitioner versus Arizona connection against the United States
that set us on this path.
New York time was coming from the petitioner versus lb
day. The court is so much more powerful.
It's grown into the 800 pound gorilla when it slam says jump.
Other branches tend to say how high we'll hear argument now. A number,
oh nine 49 George W.
Bush and Richard [inaudible] just taking for granted three words. Bush v Gore.
They decided the presidential election and, and no one blinked.
Let me just jump in for one second. Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, you could be,
if we have to say this before we close,
you could reasonably argue that Marbury versus Madison was not the big moment
when the court got its power because it really depends on what you mean when you
say power immediate.
Like I guess we were talking with our legal editor, la Ms Stalin,
constitutional scholar, Linda monk. They both said like,
look at what happens after this case. Just 30 years down the road, ish.
John Marshall's still the chief justice.
He gets into a dustup with Andrew Jackson
and this is Jackson we're talking about. So generally it was,
I would like to do horrible things to native Americans. And the court was like,
you probably
shouldn't do horrible things than native Americans. And Jackson was like,
shut up.
I don't remember asking you a God damn thing.
So essentially you had a situation where Marshall makes a ruling saying we have
to respect native American sovereignty. And Andrew Jackson famously said, oh,
supposedly said, we don't know if that's true.
Oh look,
I think it's more fun to believe that Jackson did say that it works better than
the musical. The court has made its ruling now let them enforce it.
John Marshall has made his decision now let him enforce it,
and obviously he couldn't. So to make a long set story short,
you get the trail of tears.
Thousands of native Americans were marched off their lands.
There's evidence that they were purposefully moved during the winter so that
more people would die along the way.
So while the court maybe had constitutional authority,
it didn't have actual power
until, oh wait, that's got a ring on it.
And the students are fast forward to the 1950s court orders,
schools to desegregate, they don't and the president sends them the troops,
takes Eisenhower,
Jackie's order directing the use of under putting boots on the ground picks
Kennedy,
the Alabama National Godman, putting boots on the ground takes force.
It's still so often comes down to an executive willing to put boots on the
ground in order to enforce their laws.
That's when the power becomes real. Although maybe not la,
I don't know.
A time before I went to college and even shortly after I was in college where
things were not separate. At one point as we were working on the story,
Ellie talked to his mom and she told him that when she was growing up in the mid
sixties and this is years after desegregation,
more than a decade past Brown v Board, you would still never know what happened.
No one would know it and Clark said Mississippi at that time there was a public
library, but I was not allowed to go to that library. My father,
who was Chinese, could go into the library.
So many times I sit in the car lot that went into the library to get a book that
I wanted.
And this is, this is after the passage of the Civil Rights Act even. Yes.
I'm saying high school. I graduated in 67 67. Wow.
Just yesterday as we're recording this, um,
a court had to issue a current court had to issue a nother ruling ordering a
town in Mississippi to desegregate its schools. Yeah. That,
that didn't happen five years ago. They didn't have it. That happened yesterday,
man. Yesterday. The courts can make these laws,
but if the people aren't willing to go along with it,
what do these laws mean?
I think ultimately I agree with learning hand.
He was a judge in New York in the early 19 hundreds that we place our hopes too
much upon laws and courts and constitutions that these are hopes
liberty lies in the hearts of men and women. And when it dies, there are no law,
no court, no constitution can save it.
[inaudible]
in the end, for better or worse, we,
the people still have the power.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].
Okay,
so why do we call this podcast the strange thing we called it as it turns out,
well, I guess we mentioned this at the top. Vast majority of Americans,
like 66% cannot name a single supreme court justice.
We also found that when we went out, a lot of people had no idea how many
justices there are. I do not know how many Supreme Court justices that,
I'm not sure, even 12 or a couple of hundred.
One there are seven supreme court judges,
maybe 12, nine, nine. Yes. Well, no, eight.
Uh, we think we should know about these people.
We should at least know their names.
So the title of this podcast is a pneumonic device to help you remember the
names of the justices. So their last names are Kagan,
Kennedy, Thomas Ginsburg, briars. Sorry, Briar. No.
S they're Roberts, Alito and Sotomayor. And if Merrick garland gets on,
then you've also got garland, Kagan, Kennedy, Thomas Ginsburg, Briar Roberts,
Alito Sotomayer, maybe garland. So first letter, last name, k, k.
T. G. B. R. A. S. Maybe g.
What if we turn that into a song to help you remember
kids,
you can live to robot seller,
maybe Goddamn Kittens,
the giggly bu robot. Oh, or
maybe Goddamn kittens.
[inaudible]
maybe Goddamn kittens kicked the robot.
[inaudible] Baby Goddamn kittens taper.
Oh, sorry, baby kittens.
Keep [inaudible] robot
[inaudible] [inaudible]
escaped and giggly. Whew. Oh Man. Oh some. Or
maybe goddamn. You can find that song, uh,
on our website. Radio lab.org/more. Perfect. And now you make one.
You send it to us
seriously. More perfect is produced by me. Jan have him, Rod, Susie Lichtenberg,
Tobin Lowe, Kelsey Padgett and Sean Ramez Virg with Soren Wheeler, Eliana style,
David Herman, Alex Overington, Karen Defin, Catherine Wells, Barry Finkle,
Andy Mills, Dylan Keefe, and Eva Dasher. Special thanks to Judith Resnick,
Paul Boger, Liam told Jessica Miller, Annie Mcewen, Matthew, Matt Kielty,
Elitzia, John Mead, Bernard,
Nadia Sirota and John Hanrahan Supreme Court audio is from OEA,
a free law project in collaboration with the legal information institute at
Cornell.
More perfect is funded in part by the William and Flora Hewlett Foundation,
the Charles Evans Hughes Memorial Foundation, and the Joyce Foundation.